[Music]
Khloe Kardashian has some unusual
pregnancy cravings that's the fun of it
the 33 year old reality star who's
expecting her first child later this
year took to Twitter on Friday to ask
fans for their advice on her odd
appetite
writing I feel like I need spaghetti and
I think I want a side of strawberries
and whipped cream lol is this normal
minutes later khlomoney went from that
interesting pairing to wanting pancakes
and after that dessert writing oh my god
now I want a ice-cream sandwich and
asking her sister Kim to join her on her
quest to quench her odd food desires
when it comes to food my sister Kim
always has my back her and I can chow
down at all times
Keeks where you at I'm just rolling with
it Chloe also shared on her app on
Friday sisters Kim and Kourtney have
been giving her advice on her pregnancy
style the mother-to-be says they are
quote her style gurus and have been
helping her with the challenge of
dressing her adorable bump while younger
sis and new mom Kylie has inspired her
to bear more skin
[Music]